Netflix is testing a new feature it's
gonna allow viewers to watch shows in
movies at a much faster speed you know
why they're doing that it's so people
can binge more shows in less time that's
a feature that Netflix is gonna offer
our offers now and as soon as that was
announced TV and film directors were
furious they expressed their hatred for
the idea there are a lot of articles
written about how just how furiously are
they make these movies and then it just
gets sped up
they don't want Netflix messing with the
timing of their work well I don't know
what the big deal is because TBS has a
similar feature called
ideal viewing speed they've had it for a
little while and people seem to love it
you can even use it when when binge
watching this show when you watch my
show you can want you can use this ideal
viewing speed feature take a look from
the TBS Conan home screen click watch
navigate to the episode you'd like to
see then click on the new ideal viewing
speed tab at the bottom and turn it on
hit play and enjoy Conan as it was meant
to be seen
[Music]
you'd have to think that was that funny